bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
filippo grandi il est haut commissaire
des nations unies aux réfugiés il est en
duplex avec nous depuis le siège du hcr
à genève merci à vous d'être avec nous
monsieur grandi
merci beaucoup bonjour alors il ya
quelques jours c'était la journée
mondiale des réfugiés un bien triste
jour je dois dire cette année parce que
selon votre rapport annuel qui porte sur
l'année 2000 21 il y avait presque 90
millions de déplacés dans le monde et si
on ajoute ceux qui ont été déplacés par
la guerre une ukraine on a désormais
franchi la très symbolique barre des 100
millions c'est un record
hélas un triste record comme vous l'avez
dit mais qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est
inévitable dans une dans un monde qui ne
sait plus faire la paix où les conflits
s'accumulent littéralement s'accumulent
un après l'autre est un type de conflit
qui est devenu très
très ciblée parfois souvent presque
toujours au civil comme on le voit en
ukraine d'ailleurs donc le les gens
fuient et si vous ajoutez à tout ça les
des crises les violations des droits de
l'homme
et beaucoup d'autres facteurs facilement
hélas vous arriver à ce chiffre et ce
qui est ce qui est aussi intéressant ou
tristement intéressant c'est un chiffre
qui augmente régulièrement chaque année
depuis dix ans alors évidemment il ya là
la crise ans en ukraine l'onu cité
récemment le chiffre de 8 millions qui
auraient franchi la frontière alors
évidemment il y à ça mais il ya aussi
les effets induits par cette crise en
ukraine notamment ce qu'on craint
notamment en afrique pour bientôt à
savoir la crise alimentaire qui
évidemment on peut imaginer risque de
gonfler encore ce nombre de déplacés ce
nombre de réfugiés
c'est comme s'il y avait toute une série
de cercles vicieux en action ici qui
engendre des multiples conséquences vous
avez mentionné la crise alimentaire il
faut ajouter la flambée des prix dans
beaucoup de pays
notamment en afrique au moyen orient en
asie même en amérique latine
les défis énergétiques qui sont liées à
la crise à la gare en ukraine
souvent tout cela se passe dans des pays
qui hébergent beaucoup de réfugiés ou
qui sont des des pays qui produisent des
réfugiés donc évidemment cette fragilité
ajouté ne peut que
ne peut que causer des problèmes
humanitaires y compris probablement
c'est possible des mouvements de
population on va voir et vous savez
j'ajoute j'ajoute parce que c'est
important
tout cela dans une situation où
mobiliser les ressources humanitaires
est devenu difficile parce qu'il ya une
telle mobilisation pour faire face aux
conséquences directes de la guerre en
ukraine en u can elle même dans les pays
voisins que mobiliser pour d'autres
opérations humanitaires est devenu plus
difficile donc vous voyez c'est un tas
de facteurs négatifs qui joue
les uns avec les autres et qui rendent
le travail extrêmement complexe oui
parce que évidemment vous vous parlez de
la tension occidental à européenne avant
tout sur l'ukraine mais est ce que vous
voyez déjà un effet immédiat que ce soit
sur les situations humanitaires sur
l'aide aux réfugiés ou déplacés dans
d'autres
pays on pense à l'afghanistan on pense
évidemment même si on a tendance à
l'oublier tellement ça fait longtemps à
la syrie ou à des régions comme le sahel
par exemple
bien sûr où la corne de l'afrique où en
plus de du conflit en ethiopie dont on
ne parle presque plus mais qui est
toujours là on a les effets d'une
sécheresse en somalie dans les zones
frontalières donc il ya plusieurs crises
on le voit oui vous savez on a fait nos
comptes il ya quelques semaines et on a
vu que on a plus ou moins nous sommes
une organisation qui est financée
volontairement par les gouvernements et
par d'autres nous avons plus ou moins le
même volume de contribution de l'année
passée qui était plutôt positif mais
nous avons au moins 1 milliard d'euros
en plus de besoins liés à la crise
ukrainienne donc le même volume de
contribution
face à des besoins qui sont bien
supérieurs et comme la crise en ukraine
reçoit des ressources pour pour la
réponse humanitaire ceux qui sont
pénalisés sont les opérations dans les
autres continents alors j'ai mentionné
en passant le sahel je veux quand même y
revenir parce que c'est vrai qu'on en
parle beaucoup sous l'angle des
djihadistes les attaques la sécurité la
situation humanitaire
mais il est vrai que notamment au mali
au burkina faso cela crée des réfugiés
mais aussi surtout des déplacés internes
et que ce sont des chiffres énormes dans
des pays qui sont souvent très mal
pourvu
le nombre des déplacés à l'intérieur du
burkina faso
quand je l' ai visité il ya deux ans
deux ans et demi était à peu près un
demi million de personnes tant que déjà
très important il est proche des 2
millions c'est un petit pays mais 2
millions de déplacés à l'intérieur du
pays vous avez certainement vous
souvenez certainement des des massacres
qui ont lieu il ya seulement quelques
jours qui ont déplacé d'ultérieures
un ultérieure nombre de civils cette
situation plutôt désespérée en côte
d'ivoire où j'étais pour la journée
mondiale des réfugiés la côte d'ivoire
qui a résolu son propre problème de
déplacement
voir maintenant arriver à ses frontières
des réfugiés burkinabè je dis toujours
qu'il faut il faut prêter une attention
peut être différente au sahel il ya
beaucoup d'attention pour tout ce qui
est sécuritaire je le comprends parce
que il ya des groupes armés qui sèment
la terreur et sont à la base de tout ce
déplacement mais la réponse sécuritaire
elle n'est pas suffisante il faut
investir plus de manière plus
stratégique non seulement dans
l'humanitaire mais également dans de le
développement il ya un déficit de
développement dans la région qui nourrit
lui même qui crée de l'espace pour les
groupes terroristes et pour l'adhésion
au à ces groupes de la part des jeunes
donc il faut investir beaucoup plus si
on veut vraiment éradiquer ce phénomène
catastrophique qui créé tellement de
déplacement et de problèmes humanitaires
dans cette sous-région alors on va
revenir juste après à la côte d'ivoire
ce que vous allez un petit peu nous
raconter pourquoi vous avez été là bas
mais je quand même en venir à un accord
migratoire que vous avez critiqué celui
passé entre le royaume-uni et le rwanda
on sait qu'il ya une volonté du royaume
uni d'envoyer des migrants illégaux au
rwanda un premier avion devait partir il
ya eu des recours donc il n'est pas
parti vous avez critiqué cet accord est
ce que vous craignez surtout que
d'autres pays riches se disent que c'est
peut-être un bon modèle à suivre même si
cela ne fait pas plaisir aux
organisations des droits de l'homme ou
aux gens comme vous
je ne sais même pas si c'est vraiment un
accord migratoire à mon avis si cet
accord
était mise en oeuvre ce qui n'est pas le
cas pour l'instant parce que il a été
bloqué par la cour européenne des droits
de douane de l'homme mais s'ils étaient
mises en oeuvre à mon avis ne règlerait
rien donc il n'est pas vraiment un
accord migratoire et un accord finance
un plâtre on a pas on parle beaucoup de
migrants illégaux vous l'avez dit qu'ils
seraient transférés au rwanda il s'agit
de demandeurs d'asile qui se réfugient
envoyé au rwanda c'est quand même
différent ça veut dire que la procédure
de droit d'asile est exporté du royaume
uni un pays qui a des ressources et un
système d'asile qui fonctionne à au
rwanda
qui est un pays qui hébergent déjà
beaucoup de réfugiés mais de façon
différente c'est pas des réfugiés qui
sont soumis à une détermination de statu
quo et au royaume uni ces personnes
seraient exportés dans un pays où cette
procédure n'a pas encore n'a pas les
structures pour être mises en oeuvre
donc
du point de vue légal et pratique ça ne
marche pas à notre avis et vous l'avez
dit et je conclus mais c'est le point le
plus important ça crée un précédent
vraiment négatif ça créerait un
précédent vraiment négatif je parle dans
le conditionnel parce que j'espère qu'il
va pas être mises en oeuvre
parce que si un pays comme le royaume
uni ne veut plus faire la détermination
du statut de réfugié qu'est ce que je
peux dire aux pays qui reçoivent
beaucoup plus de réfugiés et qui ont
beaucoup moins de ressources il pourrait
me dire demain mais moi aussi je ne veux
plus recevoir les gens qui la qu'ils
aillent ailleurs on va les hampes les
envoyer ailleurs ça va ça pourrait
détruire vraiment
la pratique du droit d'asile comme elle
est conçu aujourd'hui dans le nôtre est
une pratique malgré toutes les
difficultés continuent de sauver des
milliers de vies humaines chaque jour
littéralement alors monsieur grandi j'ai
évoqué la côte d'ivoire vous vous y
étiez vous étiez aussi au liberia voisin
donc la côte d'ivoire est évidemment un
pays qui a connu une grave crise
politique sécuritaire humanitaire il ya
une décennie mais aujourd'hui les
réfugiés les déplacés sont presque tous
revenus
ils sont presque tous revenus 96 % des
300 milles et plus qui était qui avaient
fui surtout dans les pays voisins de la
côte d'ivoire ces pays ont accepté une
proposition que le hr leur a fait
d'invoquer ce qu'on appelle la clause de
cessation ça c'est un terme juridique
qui
prévoit la fin du statut de réfugié pour
ceux qui se trouvent encore dans ces
pays ils auront d'autres protections qui
ont les pays ont accepté de mettre à
neuf en coordination avec la côte
d'ivoire j'étais moi même quand j'étais
un côte d'ivoire on a pu traverser la
frontière au libéria et accompagner un
des derniers convois organisés à peu
près 250 ivoiriens qui rentrait en côte
d'ivoire je vais vous dire que le moment
où les fonctionnaires
du liberia qui étaient avec nous on
remit ont remis aux
hauts fonctionnaires ivoiriens les
copies des certificats de naissance pour
les enfants ivoiriens qui étaient nés au
liberia c'était un moment pour moi de
grande émotion la fin d'un exil un futur
meilleur pour tous ces ivoiriens et la
célébration de la générosité de tous ces
pays qui pendant très longtemps je les
dis au président du liberia ensuite on
héberger les réfugiés ivoiriens filippo
grandi sur cette note positive on a
terminé cet entretien merci à vous
depuis genève et merci à vous d'avoir
voir
regardez cette interview sur france 24
rester ici pour plus d'informations
[Musique]